This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. A couple of months ago, we asked you to share coincidences you've experienced. Lots of you called in with amazing stories. Nestled among them, were two stories that themselves formed a coincidence. So I was a student at the University of Rhode Island, and we were in this writing class. This is Amanda Birch. She was talking to the teacher of her writing class and the teacher mentioned that she lived
这里是《隐性大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。几个月前，我们邀请大家分享你们经历过的巧合。许多听众打来电话，分享了精彩的故事。在这些故事中，有两段经历本身就构成了一个巧合。我曾是罗德岛大学的学生，当时我们在一门写作课上。这是阿曼达·伯奇。她当时正在和写作课老师交谈，老师提到她住在
in a small town in Vermont. The same small town it turned out where Amanda's mother had grown up. The teacher asked Amanda what her mother's maiden name was and Amanda told her. She just kind of drops her pen and she goes, you're not gonna believe this, but I live in the house where your
佛蒙特州的一个小镇上。巧合的是，那正是阿曼达的母亲长大的小镇。老师问阿曼达她母亲的娘家姓什么，阿曼达告诉了她。她差点把笔掉在地上，然后说道：“你绝对不会相信，我住的房子就是你
mother grew up. The other listener who called us was Sarah Toproth. She called us on a scratchy phone line from Paris. Sarah's an American, but it's been living in France for several years. She was at a house party and someone there told her that there was another American in the room. So she went over to say hello. They started talking and...
母亲长大的地方。”另一位给我们打电话的听众是萨拉·托普罗斯。她通过一条杂音很重的电话线从巴黎打来电话。萨拉是个美国人，但在法国已经住了好几年。她当时在一个化妆舞会上，有人告诉她房间里还有另一个美国人。于是她走过去打招呼。他们开始聊了起来……
So it turns out that this girl that I met at this house party in Paris grew up in the exact same house in Pacific New York as my father. What are the odds? We thought we might find out. This week, we'll talk about the mathematics of coincidences. That particular kind of coincidence, meeting an acquaintance or somebody you're familiar with, in a very strange place, I would say, perhaps 80% of all the coincidences I've heard fold into that category.
原来我在巴黎的这个化妆舞会上遇到的女孩，长大的房子和我父亲在纽约帕西菲克的房子一模一样。几率有多大？我们想找答案。本周，我们将探讨巧合的数学原理。那种特殊的巧合——在一个非常奇怪的地方遇到熟人或你熟悉的人，我想说，我听过的所有巧合中大约80%都属于这一类。
And we'll explore why we are drawn to coincidences, and what our fascination with them can tell us about the human mind. Whenever you see something that you can't explain, the natural human instinct is to try to understand it. But that can also mean that sometimes we over-explain things. We're starting today with a story about Whisper.
我们还将探讨为什么我们会被巧合吸引，以及我们对巧合的迷恋能告诉我们关于人类心灵的什么信息。每当你看到无法解释的事情时，人类的本能反应就是试图去理解它。但这有时也意味着我们会过度解释事物。我们今天从一个关于Whisper的故事开始。
And just so you can understand this coincidence story, we're going to first explain what Whisper is and how it works. Whisper is an app that allows users to connect anonymously online. They can post messages or secrets, these are called Whisper's, and strangers can respond with their own Whisper's. We've asked a few producers to read out some of these Whisper's. I'm secretly planning my wedding on Pinterest. own whispers. We've asked a few producers to read out some of these whispers. The messages are short about the length of a tweet and they range from the silly to the very serious. Some months ago the folks at Whisper got in touch to tell us a story about an interesting
为了让大家理解这个巧合的故事，我们首先要解释一下Whisper是什么以及它是如何运作的。Whisper是一个允许用户在网上匿名交流的应用程序。他们可以发布消息或秘密，这些被称为Whisper，而陌生人可以用他们自己的Whisper进行回复。我们请了几位制作人来朗读其中一些Whisper。我正偷偷在Pinterest上策划我的婚礼。自己的Whisper。我们请了几位制作人来朗读其中一些Whisper。这些消息很短，大约一条推文的长度，内容从愚蠢到非常严肃不等。几个月前，Whisper的工作人员联系我们，给我们讲了一个关于他们网站上发生的有趣
coincidence that happened on their site. Lauren Hudson is 27 and she turned to Whisper at one of the darkest moments of her life. I was in a really bad relationship. There was a lot of domestic violence involved and I didn't really know what to do or how to reach out to people or how to talk about it.
巧合的故事。劳伦·哈德森27岁，在她人生中最黑暗的时刻之一，她求助于Whisper。我当时在一段非常糟糕的恋爱关系中。里面有很多家庭暴力，我真的不知道该怎么办，也不知道该怎么向别人求助，或者怎么谈论这件事。
So I used the app to connect with other women and to kind of vent and like find empowerment to get away from the person that I was with. Lauren was having trouble opening up about what was happening with her friends and family. I think I was scared to be completely honest. I think I had a lot of fear and I didn't want like any police involved. I didn't want like and I didn't want any police involved. I didn't want like, I didn't want it to turn into like this whole thing. But on Whisper she could be anonymous. She could seek support without all the immediate consequences.
所以我用这个应用程序与其他女性交流，发泄一下，并寻找力量来离开我当时交往的那个人。劳伦很难向朋友和家人敞开心扉讲述发生的这一切。我想我是害怕完全诚实。我想我有很强的恐惧感，我不想牵扯进任何警察。我不想像……我不想牵扯进任何警察。我不想像，我不想把事情闹得这么大。但在Whisper上，她是匿名的。她可以寻求支持，而不用承担所有直接的后果。
It was there in one of these threads that she started talking to a man. Lauren was touched by how much compassion he seemed to have for her, a complete stranger. It was almost as if he genuinely wanted to know how I was. Even though he didn't know who I was, and he knew that it was anonymous and who knows who he's talking to, he just genuinely wanted to know if I was okay. He was in a town nearby, another coincidence perhaps, and they started exchanging messages. They connected immediately, decided to meet in person. We got together and we went to Applebee's, and we sat and we talked for like,
正是在其中的一个交流串里，她开始和一个男人聊天。劳伦被他表现出的对她这个完全陌生的人的同情心深深打动了。就好像他真的想知道我过得怎么样。尽管他不知道我是谁，而且他知道这是匿名的，谁知道他在和谁说话，但他就是真心想知道我是否还好。他住在附近的一个小镇上，也许又是一个巧合，他们开始互发消息。他们一拍即合，决定见面。我们聚在一起去了Applebee's，我们坐下来聊了大约，
I think it was like almost two hours that we just sat and talked. They became more and more inseparable. Lauren ended her unhealthy relationship and started dating this guy from Whisperr, Eric. And everything was going great. But Lauren was a little nervous about meeting Eric's family. Eric had brought Lauren home to have dinner with them and the whole time she was anxious.
我想有将近两个小时，我们只是坐着聊天。他们变得越来越形影不离。劳伦结束了那段不健康的恋爱关系，开始和这个来自Whisper的家伙埃里克约会。一切都进展顺利。但劳伦对去见埃里克的家人有点紧张。埃里克把劳伦带回家和他们一起吃晚饭，她全程都很焦虑。
Like my palms were sweating and I felt like really hot. You know, so I didn't know if like if it was going down well or if I was totally blowing it. Like I didn't know what was going on. She was especially nervous about Eric's sister, Amanda. You know, I knew when I first met her, the first couple of times that we hung out and stuff. I knew that there was a little bit of a distance there and I knew that every time I went over to hang out with Eric and his family, those walls would slowly break down. But Lauren was impatient. She and Eric were getting engaged.
比如我的手心在出汗，我感觉非常热。你知道的，所以我不知道事情进展顺利还是我彻底搞砸了。就像我不知道发生了什么一样。她对埃里克的妹妹阿曼达尤为紧张。你知道的，当我第一次见到她时，我们最初几次一起出去玩的时候，我就知道了。我知道他们之间有点距离感，而且我知道每次我去和埃里克及他的家人一起玩时，那些隔阂会慢慢打破。但劳伦很着急。她和埃里克要订婚了。
Lauren understood Amanda's attitude. She felt the same toward the girls her younger brother would bring home. Maybe I'll see them next week, or maybe I'll never see them again. You know what I mean? So that was kind of like what I had in my head. same toward the girls, her younger brother would bring home. Lauren wasn't going anywhere. She and Eric were getting engaged. Eric in fact had a flair for the romantic bringing her roses, comforting her with her favorite movie after a tough day, and he would tell his family about all this. So why couldn't Lauren break through with Amanda? All this time, Lauren was still on whisper. Now I use it instead of me looking for help, I use it to help others.
劳伦理解阿曼达的态度。对于她弟弟带回家的女孩，她也有过同样的感受。也许我下周会见到她们，或者也许我再也见不到她们了。你知道我的意思吗？所以这有点像我脑子里的想法。对于她弟弟带回家的女孩，她也有过同样的感受。劳伦可不会轻易离开。她和埃里克要订婚了。事实上，埃里克很有浪漫情调，会给她送玫瑰，在辛苦一天后用她最喜欢的电影安慰她，他还会把这一切告诉家人。那为什么劳伦就无法打破与阿曼达之间的坚冰呢？这段时间里，劳伦依然在使用Whisper。现在我用它不是为了寻求帮助，而是用它来帮助别人。
That's my way of giving back because the whisper community helped me when I needed them. One day, she started exchanging messages with a woman who was going through a very painful break-up. I sent a big message, basically saying that it's okay, everyone goes to heartaches and there will be many more people out there. As a way to offer encouragement, Lauren told a woman about her own happy relationship. The woman asked Lauren about the nicest thing her fiancee had done for her. Lauren told her about the day Eric surprised her with her favorite movie. On my birthday, I had a really bad day at work.
这是我回馈社会的方式，因为在我需要的时候，Whisper社区曾帮助过我。有一天，她开始和一个正在经历痛苦分手的女人互发消息。我发了一条长消息，大意是说没关系的，每个人都会经历心碎，外面还会有更多的人。为了鼓励对方，劳伦向那个女人讲述了她自己幸福的恋情。那个女人问劳伦她的未婚夫为她做过最美好的事情是什么。劳伦向她讲述了埃里克用她最喜欢的电影给她惊喜的那一天。在我生日那天，我在工作上度过了糟糕的一天。
It was like one of those days where you wake up and just from the moment you put your feet on the floor, everything goes wrong. So I didn't want to see him that day. I was just miserable. I just wanted to be home. Like, I was just, like, I just want to go to bed. And he surprised me with these beautiful flowers, these roses, and he had the notebook, which is my favorite, like, sappy love story of all time.
那就像那种你一醒来，从你把脚放到地上的那一刻起，所有事情都不顺利的日子。所以我那天不想见他。我只是觉得很痛苦。我只想呆在家里。就像，我只是觉得，我只想去睡觉。但他用这些美丽的鲜花、这些玫瑰给了我一个惊喜，他还带着《恋恋笔记本》，那是我有生以来最喜欢的、最俗气的爱情故事。
Lauren finished telling her story and waited for her reply. Her first response after I sent that story to her, she's like, Lauren. Like she, Lauren, I was like, how do you know my name? You know, because it's all anonymous. And she's like, this is Amanda. Amanda, Eric's sister, the very person, she'd been trying so desperately to connect with in real life.
劳伦讲完她的故事，等待着对方的回复。在我把那个故事发给她之后，她的第一反应是，劳伦。就像她，劳伦，当时我想：你怎么知道我的名字？你知道的，因为这一切都是匿名的。然后她说：我是阿曼达。阿曼达，埃里克的妹妹，也就是她一直在现实生活中拼命想要建立联系的那个人。
Lauren says this coincidence changed her whole relationship with Amanda, connecting random very person, she'd been trying so desperately to connect with in real life. Lauren says this coincidence changed her whole relationship with Amanda. Connecting randomly online and revealing intimate details about themselves, made the two women feel closer. Many of us have experienced these kinds of coincidences. You bump into your kindergarten friend, your first day in college, or you meet someone at a party and discover she lives in your dad's childhood home in Prokipsi. When these kinds of coincidences happen in our lives, they feel like magic.
劳伦说，这个巧合改变了她与阿曼达的整个关系，将那些随机正是她一直在现实生活中拼命想要建立联系的那个人。劳伦说，这个巧合改变了她与阿曼达的整个关系。在网上随机相连并透露彼此的私密细节，让这两个女人感到更加亲密。我们许多人都经历过这种巧合。你在上大学的第一天撞见了幼儿园的朋友，或者你在派对上遇到某人，发现她住在你爸爸在波基普西的童年老家里。当这种巧合发生在我们的生活中时，它们感觉就像魔法一样。
But as any mathematician will tell you, things that feel unusual or even impossible are actually fairly common. Mathematician Joseph Muser knows this, but he was reluctant to write a book that would dispel the magic. In the end though, Joseph did write his book, it's called Fluke, the math and myth of coincidence. It's full of stories of people who find themselves experiencing things that feel so unlikely. But Joseph Maeser says, if you study this for a while, the coincidences start to fall into certain categories.
但正如任何数学家都会告诉你的那样，那些感觉不寻常甚至不可能的事情实际上相当普遍。数学家约瑟夫·梅瑟深知这一点，但他起初并不想写一本会打破这种魔法的书。不过最终，约瑟夫还是写了他的书，书名叫《侥幸：巧合的数学与迷思》。书中充满了各种故事，讲述人们发现自己经历的事情感觉是如此不可思议。但约瑟夫·梅瑟说，如果你研究一段时间，这些巧合就会开始落入某些类别。
And the stories we heard from our two listeners, as well as Lauren's story about meeting her soon-to-be sister-in-law in Whisper are all basically the same type of coincidence, which in itself is not a coincidence. If you categorize these coincidences to, let's say, ten different categories, that particular kind of coincidence, meeting an acquaintance or somebody you're familiar with. In a very strange place, I would say perhaps 80% of all the coincidence I've heard fold into that category. Joseph Mauser says the reason these coincidences feel extraordinary, but actually are not so extraordinary, is because of a common misconception about the number of people we think we actually know.
我们从两位听众那里听到的故事，以及劳伦在Whisper上遇到她即将成为的小姑子的故事，基本上都是同一种类型的巧合，而这本身并不是巧合。如果你把这些巧合归纳为，比方说十个不同的类别，那种特殊的巧合——在一个非常奇怪的地方遇到熟人或你熟悉的人。我想说，我听过的所有巧合中大约80%都落入这一类别。约瑟夫·梅瑟说，这些巧合之所以让人感觉非同寻常，但实际上并非如此，是因为人们对我们实际认识的人数存在普遍的误解。
People think that their address book is essentially the people they know and it turns out that any particular address book is about 1% of the people they actually know in some way. In other words, a neighbor, some of the bump into in the street, but the dress book is about 1% of the people they know. As a result, the odds of bumping into someone you know are much greater than you think, because you know many more people than you think. Sometimes math can help us understand the magic. Magic like winning the lottery, not just once, but several times. That's what happened to a woman named Joan Ginther.
人们认为他们的通讯录基本上就是他们认识的人，但事实证明，任何特定的通讯录大约只占他们实际通过某种方式认识的人的1%。换句话说，邻居，在街上偶遇的人，但通讯录只占他们认识的人的1%。因此，偶遇熟人的几率比你想象的要大得多，因为你认识的人比你想象的要多得多。有时数学可以帮助我们理解魔法。比如赢得彩票的魔法，不仅中一次，而是中好几次。一个叫琼·金瑟的女人就经历了这样的事。
In 1993, I think it was, she won $5.4 million in Texas Lotto. 13 years later, she won again $2 million. And then a few years after that, she won $3 million. And then in 2010, she won $3 million, and then in 2010, she won $10 million. What are the odds of one person winning the lottery four times? Yeah, the odds are, I think somebody made a calculation, and I did too, that the odds are about 18 Septilion to one against it happening. 18 Septilion to one against it happening.
我想大概是在1993年，她赢得了德克萨斯州彩票的540万美元。13年后，她再次赢得了200万美元。然后几年后，她又赢得了300万美元。接着在2010年，她赢得了300万美元，然后又在2010年，她赢得了1000万美元。一个人连续四次中彩票的几率是多少？是的，几率是——我想有人做过计算，我也算过——发生的几率大约是18万亿亿分之一。发生的几率大约是18万亿亿分之一。
18 Septilion to one. That's incomprehensible. For those who are not mathematicians, a Septilion is one followed by 24 zeros. But Joseph Mauser says, we're actually asking the wrong question. Think about it this way. If I buy a lottery ticket and I ask the question, what are the odds that I will win? My odds are very small. But if I ask, what are the odds that anyone will win the lottery? In a country of hundreds of millions of people, the odds are actually much higher. So if you ask the question slightly differently, not what are the odds that Joan Guinter will win the lottery four times, but what are the odds that anyone will win four times? You get a very different answer. I think I calculated one point about 5 million to one, which is not anywhere near the septillions. It's about 5 million to one, and that takes into account the fact that we have thousands
18万亿亿分之一。这简直无法理解。对于非数学家来说，“万亿亿”（Septilion）是一个后面跟着24个零的数字。但约瑟夫·梅瑟说，我们实际上问错了问题。换个角度想。如果我买了一张彩票，然后问：我中奖的几率是多少？我的几率非常小。但如果我问：任何人中彩票的几率是多少？在一个拥有数亿人口的国家里，这个几率实际上要高得多。所以如果你稍微改变一下问题，不是问琼·金瑟连续四次中彩票的几率是多少，而是问任何人连续四次中奖的几率是多少？你会得到一个非常不同的答案。我想我计算的结果大约是500万分之一，这与万亿亿分之一相去甚远。大约是500万分之一，这考虑到了我们拥有数千个
of lottery in the world. I mean, there are many lotteries and many of them are big time lotteries. So 5 million to one, still unlikely, but not incomprehensible. What makes it even more comprehensible is the fact that most lottery winners don't stop gambling when they win. And you do find that almost everybody who does win a lottery fairly big time spends all that money or much of that money in trying to win again. Joseph Miser says this might have been the case with John Ginter. You win 5.4 million dollars. You have you have a money to play with. You have house money. So you're you're taking the house money to bet again and
世界上有各种彩票。我的意思是，有很多彩票，其中许多都是大型彩票。所以500万分之一，仍然不太可能，但并非不可理解。更让人能够理解的是这样一个事实：大多数彩票得主在赢了之后并不会停止赌博。你会发现，几乎所有赢得一笔相当大彩票的人，都会把所有的钱或大部分钱花在试图再次中奖上。约瑟夫·梅瑟说，琼·金瑟可能就是这种情况。你赢了540万美元。你手头有了可以支配的资金。你有了“赌场给的钱”。所以你是拿着“赌场给的钱”再去下注，
her odds of winning a second time are better than most people because she's got the money to play with. She wins the second time, then she's playing with more money. And you can see the between the first winning and the second winning, it was 13 years, between the second winning and the third, it was only two years, and between the third and the fourth was only two years as well. So Joseph Mauser can wrap his head around what happened to Joan Gynther, but there are some coincidences that just defy mathematical interpretation. Joseph told me one of his favorite stories about a 19th century French poet Emil de
她第二次中奖的几率比大多数人都要好，因为她有资本可以玩。她第二次中奖了，然后她用更多的钱在玩。你可以看到，第一次中奖和第二次中奖之间间隔了13年，第二次中奖和第三次中奖之间只隔了2年，第三次和第四次之间也只隔了2年。所以约瑟夫·梅瑟能够理解琼·金瑟身上发生的事情，但有些巧合确实违背了数学解释。约瑟夫给我讲了他最喜欢的故事之一，关于19世纪法国诗人埃米尔·德尚。
Champ. Emil de Champ, as a teenager, he meets a man by the name of a strange name, Monsieur de Forti-Bou. He turns out to be an immigrant from England, and a Forti-Bou introduces him to a plum pudding. It's a very English dish that's almost unheard of in France. Ten years go by, and Dixamp is passing a restaurant in Paris. There's a sign on the window saying that they have plum pudding on their menu. But when Dixamp goes inside, he stole the last of the plum pudding was just sold to a gentleman
埃米尔·德尚在青少年时期，遇到过一个名字叫怪名“福蒂布先生”（Monsieur de Forti-Bou）的男人。原来他是一个来自英国的移民，福蒂布向他介绍了一种在法国几乎闻所未闻的非常地道的英国菜——梅子布丁。十年过去了，德尚路过巴黎的一家餐馆。窗户上挂着一个招牌，上面写着他们的菜单上有梅子布丁。但当德尚走进去时，他被告知最后一份梅子布丁刚刚卖给了一位
sitting in the back. The waiter calls out loud. Mr. DeFotinbou, would you be willing to share your plum pudding with this gentleman? You're as pass. D'Sham is now at a dinner party with some friends. The host announces an unusual dessert will be served. Plum pudding. And the shamp jokes that one of the guests to arrive must be Mr. De Forte Boone.
坐在后面的绅士。服务员大声喊道：福蒂布先生，你愿意和这位绅士分享你的梅子布丁吗？你身在何处。德尚现在正和一些朋友参加晚宴。主人宣布将上一道不同寻常的甜点：梅子布丁。德尚开玩笑说，即将到达的一位客人一定就是福蒂布先生。
Well, as soon as the doorbell rings, then Mr. De Forte Boone is announced. And he enters, he's an old man by now, but the shamp recognizes him. Mr. De Fort and the food looks around and realizes that he's in the wrong apartment. He was invited to a dinner, but not in that apartment. I love that because it's a triple coincidence
嗯，门铃一响，福蒂布先生就被通报了。他走了进来，现在已经是个老人了，但德尚认出了他。福蒂布先生环顾四周，意识到自己走错了公寓。他被邀请去参加晚宴，但不是在这间公寓。我非常喜欢这个故事，因为这是一个三重巧合，
and it has a beautiful story element with it. I mean, that's so magnificent. And that's why, that's the kind of coincidence I love to hear. Joseph Maser, Professor of Mathematics and author of Fluke, the Math and Myth of Coincidence. When we come back, we're going to look at what Coincidence's reveal about the mind, in particular, and fascinated by something I've observed in my own life. When I experience a coincidence, it invariably feels more meaningful to me than it does to others.
并且它具有一个美丽的叙事元素。我的意思是，这真是太宏伟了。这就是为什么——这也是我最喜欢听的那类巧合。约瑟夫·梅瑟，数学教授，《侥幸：巧合的数学与迷思》的作者。稍后回来，我们将探讨巧合揭示了关于大脑的什么，特别是，我对我自己在生活中观察到的一种现象感到着迷。当我经历巧合时，它对我来说总是比对其他人更有意义。
Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. I'm fascinated by coincidences and could listen for hours to stories about them. But what is it that so fascinates us about these moments in life? At the University of Chicago, psychologists Nick Eppley thinks he might have one answer. He's the author of the book mind-wise. To understand how Eppley thinks about coincidences, I need to take a moment and explain his broader work to you first.
请不要走开。欢迎回到《隐性大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我对巧合着迷不已，可以连续听上几个小时关于巧合的故事。但是，到底是什么让我们对生活中的这些时刻如此着迷呢？芝加哥大学的心理学家尼克·埃普利认为他可能找到了答案。他是《思想感知》（Mindwise）一书的作者。为了理解埃普利对巧合的看法，我需要先花点时间向大家解释他更广泛的研究。
Eppley's book examines how we read the mental states and intentions of other people. This is a remarkably useful skill, but we sometimes misapply it. We sometimes attribute intentionality to things that aren't even living, especially when they're out of the ordinary. For example, we don't personify a sunny day, but we give hurricanes a name, Katrina, Sandy, Andrew. After Hurricane Katrina, the mayor of New Orleans said, God must be mad at America. This isn't new.
埃普利的书探讨了我们如何解读他人的心理状态和意图。这是一项非常有用技能，但我们有时会误用它。我们有时会将意图归诸于甚至没有生命的事物，尤其是当它们不同寻常的时候。例如，我们不会将晴天拟人化，但我们会给飓风起名字：卡特里娜、桑迪、安德鲁。卡特里娜飓风过后，新奥尔良市长说，上帝一定是对美国发火了。这并不是什么新鲜事。
For centuries, people have ascribed intentionality to natural forces. We think storms, droughts, and earthquakes must have a mind of their own. This general tendency to explain behaviors in terms of purpose or intent or meaning is often quite a successful thing to do. Turns out we live with other people who do have intentions and goals and foresight and planning and meaning behind their actions. And so by and large that tendency to make those kinds of attributions to other people is a good way to learn about each other, is a good way to explain why other people did something in the past, to predict how they're likely to behave in the future.
几个世纪以来，人们一直将意图归诸于自然力量。我们认为风暴、旱灾和地震一定有它们自己的思想。这种用目的、意图或意义来解释行为的普遍倾向通常是非常成功的做法。事实证明，我们周围的其他生活着的人确实有他们的意图、目标、远见、规划以及行动背后的意义。因此，总的来说，对其他人做出这种归因的倾向是了解彼此的好方法，是解释其他人过去为什么那样做的好方法，也是预测他们未来可能如何行为的好方法。
But the problem with any kind of good tool is that sometimes we use it a little too much. And that's what happens in these cases where you're trying to explain the behavior of something that doesn't really have a sensible explanation for it. Some random events, some chance occurrence, some physical anomaly, some weather pattern that crops up that might not in fact have a mind behind it. This is why we are fascinated by robots that move in unpredictable ways. What we found was that when people were given a description of an object that made it sound unpredictable, like you couldn't anticipate its actions.
但任何好工具的问题在于，有时我们会过度使用它。这就是当你在试图解释某种没有合理合理解释的事物的行为时所发生的情况。一些随机事件、一些机缘巧合、一些物理异常、或者突然出现可能背后并没有主观意识的某种天气模式。这就是为什么我们对以不可预测方式移动的机器人如此着迷。我们发现的是，当人们被赋予对一个物体的描述，使其听起来不可预测，就像你无法预料它的行动一样。
That's when people described it or reported that it had more mental states. They were more willing to say that the object has a mind of its own, that it has intentions, for instance. And I don't think this is totally counterintuitive that is a mind. If you see, for instance, a billured ball sitting on a table, another ball comes along and hits it,
这时候人们就会描述或报告说它有更多的心理状态。他们更愿意说这个物体有它自己的思想，比如它有意图。我不认为这完全是反直觉的，这就是一个思想。如果你看到，比如说，一张台球桌上放着一个台球，另一个球过来撞击它，
and that ball rolls off in the predicted direction, well, you don't need anything to explain that. But if you've got a ball sitting on a table, and it suddenly starts rolling around randomly, well, then you've got something to explain. And in these cases, sometimes people look to the inside of an agent, give it a mind, maybe the ball is possessed, maybe there's a demon controlling it, moving it around the table.
然后那个球按预期的方向滚开，好吧，你不需要任何东西来解释这一点。但如果你有一个球放在桌子上，它突然开始随机乱滚，好吧，那你就得有东西来解释了。在这些情况下，有时人们会去寻找代理内部的东西，给它一个思想，也许这个球被附身了，也许有个恶魔在控制它，让它在桌子上移动。
Sometimes people attribute a mind to something when it's not there, but they do that as an effort to explain what's going on in this autonomous, in this autonomous agent. And they're more likely to do that when an agent behaves somewhat unpredictably. I was over at a friend's house and my friend has a wonderful pool and he had set this underwater rumble for the lack of a better term to clean the bottom of the pool. So it sort of rolls around the bottom of the pool
有时人们会将思想归于某个并不存在的东西，但他们这样做是为了解释这个自主代理内部正在发生的事情。当一个代理的行为表现得有些不可预测时，他们更有可能这样做。我有一次去一个朋友家，我朋友有一个非常棒的泳池，他设置了一个水下Roomba（找不到更好的词来称呼它）来清洁泳池底部。所以它有点像在泳池底部滚来滚去，
and it goes in this completely random fashion, right? So it just runs for a couple of hours. It's cleaning the bottom of the pool and I found myself fascinated just watching it because the fact that you can't predict what it's going to do next makes it just more interesting and more alive in a way than something that moves in a very predictable fashion. Absolutely. Something that moves robotically, very predictably, that is just a mindless machine. But when your roomba is going around randomly,
它以这种完全随机的方式行进，对吧？所以它就这样运行几个小时。它在清洁泳池底部，我发现自己看得入迷，因为你无法预测它下一步会做什么，这使得它比那些以高度可预测的方式移动的事物更有趣，在某种意义上也更有生命力。完全正确。像机器人一样移动、非常可预测的事物，那只是一台没有思想的机器。但当你的Roomba到处乱跑时，
well, now it wants to go over there a little bit. Now it wants to move over here. Now it realizes it didn't clean that side of the pool over there. Things that behave randomly start to get a little sense of a mind. Now people aren't crazy. You don't think it's like your mother, right, or your spouse who's vacuuming the living room. But it starts to look just a little bit more mindful. In fact, the Rumbas are good example. People actually do name their Rumbas. You can buy outfits to dress it up.
好吧，现在它想去那边一点。现在它想挪到这里。现在它意识到它还没有清理那边泳池的那一侧。随机行为的事物开始带有一点点思想的感觉。当然，人们并没有疯。你不会觉得它像你的母亲，对吧，或者是你在客厅吸尘的配偶。但它开始看起来确实更有思想了。事实上，Roomba就是一个很好的例子。人们实际上真的会给他们的Roomba起名字。你还可以买衣服来装扮它。
If you Google this online, you'll find all kinds of examples of people thinking of their Rumbas having perhaps a little bit more of a mind than it really does. I want to talk to you a little bit about the subject of coincidences. And I thought of you in your work because it feels to me that when something unusual happens to us and we stop and we say, that is weird. I was just reading this word in a book a second ago and someone in the room around me mentions the very same word. And it makes you stop and look up just like I stop and
如果你在谷歌上搜索这个，你会发现各种各样的例子，人们认为他们的Roomba可能比实际情况拥有更多的思想。我想和你聊聊关于巧合的话题。我想到了你和你的工作，因为我觉得当一些不寻常的事情发生在我们身上时，我们会停下来然后说：这太诡异了。我刚才在书里读到这个词，而我周围房间里的某个人就提到了同一个词。这让你停下来抬头看，就像我停下来看那个水下的Roomba一样。
look at that underwater rumba. Absolutely. That's a case where something unusual happens. It was unpredictable and you try to explain it. You can explain these kinds of random coincidences in lots of different ways. There are lots of different kinds of causal structures we might be able to put on it. But some of them involve giving it more meaning than it actually has. This is what underwater rumbers have to do with coincidences.
完全正确。那是发生不寻常事情的情况。它是不可预测的，而你试图去解释它。你可以用很多不同的方式来解释这种随机的巧合。我们可以把它放入许多不同种类的因果结构中。但其中一些涉及赋予它比实际更多的意义。这就是水下Roomba与巧合的关系。
Like a robot that does something unexpected, coincidences cry out for meaning or explanation because they're out of the ordinary. We start to seek patterns even when they aren't any. My favorite example of this in the world of psychology is actually phenomena first documented by my PhD advisor, Tom Gilevich, and the brilliant psychologist, Amos Tversky, is the illusion of the hot hand in basketball.
就像一个做出意料之外举动的机器人一样，巧合由于不同寻常而强烈要求得到意义或解释。即使根本没有规律，我们也开始寻找规律。在心理学界，我对此最喜欢的例子其实是由我的博士导师汤姆·吉洛维奇（Tom Gilovich）和杰出的心理学家阿莫斯·特沃斯基（Amos Tversky）首次记录的现象，也就是篮球运动中“手气热”（Hot Hand）的错觉。
Danny Green again from downtown. He said six and a row are going back to game two. The myth is that, when shooting free throws, basketball players get on a roll. People believe that basketball players get a hot hand, and that their times when they're on and the chance of making a basket is higher after they've just made one than after they've just missed one. Eplea is insane basketball players don't have streaks. He's saying we draw the wrong conclusion about these streaks. Let's imagine that they're a good shooter and they shoot 50% from the field.
丹尼·格林再次在三分线外出手。他说连进六球，比赛回到了第二局。迷信的说法是，在罚球时，篮球运动员会进入顺风顺水的状态。人们相信篮球运动员会有“热手”，并且在他们刚刚投进一个球之后，再次投进的几率要比刚刚投失之后更高。埃普利说篮球运动员并没有连中。他是说我们对这些连中得出了错误的结论。让我们假设他们是一个优秀的射手，全场命中率为50%。
That 50% probability is going to produce a lot more clumping. In the baskets, than people expect. People expect a coin flip, a 50% probability to alternate a lot more than it actually does. And so when you see randomness out in the world, it actually looks more ordered to you than it really is. Echelie described a party trick that demonstrates this phenomenon. You can do this too. Give everyone in the party a note card and have them write down what they think 30 coin flips would look like. H, if they think it will be heads, T, if they think it will be tails.
这种50%的概率会产生比人们预期的更多的聚集。在进球方面，比人们预期的要多。人们期望抛硬币、50%的概率应该比实际情况有更多的交替。因此，当你看到世界上的随机性时，它实际上对你来说比真实的随机性看起来更有秩序。埃普利描述了一个展示这种现象的聚会把戏。你也可以这样做。给聚会上的每个人一张便条纸，让他们写下他们认为抛30次硬币会是什么样子。如果他们认为是正面，就写H；如果他们认为是反面，就写T。
You then, as master magician, leave the room and you have one person come up and actually flip a coin 30 times. That person writes down the actual sequence of coin flips on a note card and then collects all the note cards, the real and the imagined sequences, and puts them together. You the magician then come back into the room and identify the card that was the real coin flip. And the way you do this is you look for the card that has the longest runs because people's imagination doesn't presume that a 50-50 probability will produce very long runs.
然后，作为魔术大师的你离开房间，让一个人上来实际抛30次硬币。这个人把真实的抛硬币序列写在一张便条纸上，然后收集所有的便条纸——真实的和想象的序列，把它们放在一起。作为魔术师的你随后回到房间，找出那张记录了真实抛硬币结果的卡片。你这样做的方法是寻找拥有最长连续记录的卡片，因为人们的想象力不会假设50对50的概率会产生非常长的连续记录。
And so people's imagined coin flips will alternate more than the real coin flip will. And that's how you can identify the real one from the fake ones. And I think that illusion that we have, that randomness alternates, or as more fancy than it actually is, that there's less clumping is also the thing that gives rise to these other phenomena where we see randomness in the world, and we see more predictability or intentionality than actually exist in it. When we asked our listeners to share coincidences with us, many of them wrote in with really interesting examples of things that happened to them. One thing that I was
因此，人们想象中的抛硬币交替次数会比真实的抛硬币更多。这就是你如何从虚假的卡片中识别出真实卡片的方法。我认为我们所拥有的那种幻觉——即随机性是交替出现的，或者比实际情况更花哨，即聚集较少——也是产生其他现象的原因，我们在世界上看到随机性时，会看到比实际存在的更多的可预测性或意图性。当我们请听众与我们分享巧合时，许多人写信分享了发生在他们身上的非常有趣的事情。有一件事让我
struck by is the sense that sometimes a coincidence seems more meaningful to you than it does to someone else. So for example, when I'm reading a book and I come by an unusual word and then someone in the room mentions that same word, to me it feels like it's a sign of something. But if I would have told you, I say, Nick, you know, this happened to me yesterday, you'd say, yeah, sure, that's going to happen once every month or so. It's exactly what you would expect if you believe the laws of probability. Why do you think it is that coincidences are more meaningful to us than to other people? That's a really good question. I actually don't know that I've seen any research that demonstrates that phenomena, but that
印象深刻，那就是有时一个巧合对你来说似乎比对其他人更有意义。例如，当我正在读一书，偶然看到一个不寻常的词，然后房间里的某个人提到了那个词，对我来说，这感觉像是某种征兆。但如果我告诉你，我说：尼克，你知道吗，这昨天发生在我身上，你可能会说：哦，当然，这种事大概每个月都会发生一次。如果你相信概率定律，这正是你所预期的。你认为为什么巧合对我们来说比对其他人更有意义？这是一个非常好的问题。我其实不知道我是否见过任何研究证明这种现象，但我
strikes me as a very compelling hypothesis. I think that's probably likely to be right. And I think the reason why coincidences seem very meaningful in the first place is that you're trying to explain them. You and I both thought of the word propeller at the same time. How on earth could that be that Shankar was thinking about propeller at the same time that I was?
觉得这是一个非常引人注目的假设。我认为这很可能是正确的。我认为巧合之所以首先显得非常有意义，是因为你正试图解释它们。你和我同时想到了“螺旋桨”（propeller）这个词。尚卡尔怎么可能在我想到螺旋桨的同时也在想螺旋桨呢？
And so you're trying to explain that. You're focusing on that event that just happened to you. It has personal relevance to you. That makes it impactful. But it also makes you somewhat myopic. And what we don't think about are all of the other things that any of us in the room could have thought about at the same time, that might also have seemed amazing to us.
所以你正试图解释这一点。你专注于刚刚发生在自己身上的那个事件。它对你具有个人相关性。这使它具有影响力。但这也让你变得有点目光短浅。而我们没有去想的是，房间里的我们任何人当时可能想到的所有其他事情，这些事情对我们来说也可能显得很神奇。
We're trying to explain this one thing because it's so meaningful to us. It just happened to us. Other people are less likely to be that myopic, I think, and so there would be likely to think about other things that could have happened to you, which would make it seem less amazing to them. We of course experience the Sarsals here at the show, when two listeners called in with
我们正试图解释这唯一的一件事，因为它对我们太有意义了。它刚刚发生在我们身上。其他人没那么容易变得目光短浅，我认为，所以他们更有可能会去想其他可能发生在你身上的事情，这会使它在他们看来没那么神奇。我们在节目中当然也经历过类似的星光时刻，当时两位听众打来电话，分享了
eerily similar coincidence stories. I describe these two stories to Nick about women who ran into people who turned out to live in the very same house where the women's parents had grown up. So these are not just two coincidences. These are two coincidences that both happened to us at Hidden Brain, which seems truly extraordinary, Nick. How could that possibly be that you get these two that are exactly the same as magic
诡异相似的巧合故事。我向尼克描述了这两个故事，关于两个女性遇到了后来证明住在她们父母当年长大时同一栋房子里的人。所以这些不只是两个巧合。这是两个巧合，而且都发生在我们《隐性大脑》节目组身上，这看起来真的非同寻常，尼克。怎么可能会有这两个故事，它们和魔法一模一样，
as what it is, Sean Carr? You're magical. That's really just all I wanted to hear you say, Nick, it's been 20 minutes to get that out of you. Yeah. Eventually we have to give into the laws of probability. There's nothing that can explain that, right? Nick, I want to thank you for talking with us today.
尚卡尔，你是魔术师。这其实就是我一直想听你说的，尼克，花了我20分钟才从你嘴里套出这句话。对。最终我们不得不向概率定律屈服。没有什么可以解释这一点，对吧？尼克，我要感谢你今天与我们交谈。
Yeah, thanks for having me. Nick Eppley is the author of Mindwise, how we understand what others think, believe, feel, and want. This week's episode was produced by Mack Penman and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our staff also includes Chris Benderer, Karamakar Callison and Renee Clarke. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. There are so many people who make this podcast possible. We usually don't mention all of them in our credits.
好的，谢谢邀请我。尼克·埃普利是《思想感知：我们如何理解他人的想法、信念、感受和欲望》一书的作者。本周的节目由马克·彭曼（Mack Penman）制作，珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）剪辑。我们的团队还包括克里斯·本德尔（Chris Benderer）、卡拉马卡·卡利森（Karamakar Callison）和蕾妮·克拉克（Renee Clarke）。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）。有这么多人让这个播客得以实现。我们通常不会在鸣谢中提及所有人。
Starting today, we're going to acknowledge a different unsung hero each episode. This week, that person is Matilda P.R. who is a project manager here at NPR. She knows everything about everything. She's always generous with her time and her knowledge. Thank you, Matilda. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you liked this episode, give us a review. It'll help other people find the show.
从今天开始，我们每期将表彰一位不同的幕后英雄。本周的那个人是马蒂尔达·P·R（Matilda P.R.），她是NPR的一名项目经理。她无所不知。她总是慷慨地奉献她的时间和知识。谢谢你，马蒂尔达。想收听更多《隐性大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们，也可以在当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这期节目，请给我们写个评价。这会帮助其他人找到这个节目。
I'm Shankar Vaitanthu, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。